as if we don't have enough problems in
this country the specter of racist trees
now haunts America like a demon
ever since local officials in Palm
Springs California out there in the
desert in the heat identified a group of
tamarisk trees at a local golf course as
being racist we've been seeing those
kinds of trees everywhere is it a
coincidence that a pine tree resembles a
Klansman hood what does the weeping
willow weep for if not the end of Jim
Crow are other trees complicit in all of
this Larry alders a radio show host from
the state of California he's a lifelong
resident he's been watching carefully
Larry what's going on out there in Palm
Springs if you could sum it up for us
I think it's climate change it's hard
it's hard to say Tucker this is
California this is where the governor
just signed a measure to hike up the
minimum wage to $15 an hour after say
after saying and admitting that minimum
wage measures don't make quote much
economic sense close quote so go figure
it's all about making black people feel
better about the past about Jim Crow
about slavery as if that's the issue
facing black America a news bulletin for
30 or 40 years Tucker black score higher
on self-esteem tests than do whites and
Asians the suicide rate for whites is
higher than the suicide rate for blacks
the issue is not where the blacks feel
good or bad about themselves the issue
is what do we do about that part of
black America that is broken that is not
doing well and the number one problem
facing black America has nothing to do
with white racism or racist trees it has
to do with the fact that 73 percent of
black kids are raised without fathers
and I didn't say it Obama said a kid
raised a lot of dead it's five times
more likely to be poor nine times more
likely to drop out of school and 20
times more likely to end up in jail so
let's talk about what's causing so many
women to marry the government and so
many men to abandon their financial and
moral responsibilities that ought to be
the conversation but it isn't it
it never is in fact her scolded for
bringing up but its enormous ly sad I
just find it so interesting in growing
up in California around liberals there
was really no greater sin than cutting
down a tree a tree was even more they
were called tree huggers literally there
these are racist trees though of course
and Tucker in California you have a
governor that does not support vouchers
even though the majority of urban
parents black and brown want vouchers
the Democratic Party is opposed to
vouchers yet 95% of black people pull
the lever for the party that in my
opinion has put in an obstacle in front
of their kids getting the education
which of course at the route to the
middle class so go figure
see I just look here's what I want is
not everyone to agree with me but at
least to have a conversation about
things that actually matter rather than
frivolous things and one of the reasons
we've highlighted the racist tree story
is because it is so self-evidently
stupid that maybe it'll awaken people to
the frivolous nature of the conversation
I mean why are we having conversations
about test scores and marriage and drug
use not just in the black community but
in every community in America absolutely
absolutely I reminded Don Lemon when I
was last on CNN maybe that's why I was
last on yeah that in 1997 Time magazine
and CNN did a poll of black teens and
white teens and asked them both whether
or not racism was a major problem in
America and not too surprisingly both
white teens and black team said yes but
then they asked black teens is racism a
big problem a minor problem or no
problem in your own daily lives and
almost 90% of black teens said ray said
there was no problem or a minor problem
in my own daily life in fact more black
teens and white teens said failure to
take advantage of available
opportunities was a bigger problem than
racism so what are we talking about
racist trees take a wand and wave it
over America and remove every smidgen of
racism from the hearts of white America
we're still going to have the problem of
young people having yelled and they
can't take care of of men abandoning the
responsibility of government schools
that don't work of bad economic policies
like minimum wage that destroy jobs are
porous borders where you have illegal
workers yelling skills challenging
workers in the inner-city and on and on
and on those are the same thing America
let's have a conversation about oh
you're right you're absolutely right no
one says it better than you do Larry
thank you great to see you Merry
Christmas